>> Bill: FROM OHIO, THE
GOVERNOR PLANNING TO REOPEN THE
STATE.
GOVERNOR MIKE DEVINE IS WITH ME
LIVE AND WELCOME BACK TO OUR
PROGRAM, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
YOU ARE ONE OF THE FIRST
GOVERNORS OUTSIDE THE NORTHEAST
OR THE AMERICAN WEST TO SHUT
THINGS DOWN.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING IN YOUR
STATE TODAY?
>> WE HAVE FLATTEN THE CURVE.
IT’S BEEN STEADY FOR ABOUT EIGHT
DAYS AND NINE DAYS NOW, SO WE
ARE HAPPY ABOUT THAT FROM A
HAPPIER WHEN IT STARTS GOING
DOWN AND MEANWHILE I LOOK AT THE
HOSPITAL ADMISSIONS WHICH IS A
LAGGING INDICATOR CERTAINLY BUT
IT’S A GOOD INDICATOR OF WHERE
WE ARE.
SO AS I TOLD THE PEOPLE OF OHIO
YESTERDAY, THE MONSTER IS STILL
LOOSE AND IT’S GOING TO BE OUT
THERE IN OHIO AND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY UNTIL WE GET THE SHOT
THAT WILL TAKE CARE OF IT.
AND WILL PROTECT US.
SO WE’VE GOT TO CONTINUE TO BE
VERY CAREFUL.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE COMPROMISED
MEDICAL CONDITION HAVE TO BE
VERY CAREFUL, BUT WE THINK WE
CAN DO IS THERE’S BEEN
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE BEEN
ALLOWED TO STAY OPEN BECAUSE
THEY WERE ESSENTIAL AND SOME OF
THEM, MOST OF THEM HAVE DONE A
VERY, VERY GOOD JOB AND BEING
SAFE.
THEY HAVE THE DISTANCING, THE
HAND WASHING, THEY HAVE THE
STAGGERED LUNCHES, ALL OF THE
THINGS AND SO WE THINK THERE
WERE OTHER BUSINESSES OUT THERE
THAT AREN’T REALLY ESSENTIAL
TECHNICALLY, BUT THAT WOULD BE
SIMILAR.
WE ARE GOING TO TRY TO START
WITH THEM AND OPEN THE STATE
BACK UP.
WE ARE GOING TO BE VERY, VERY
CAREFUL AND GOING TO TAKE IT ONE
STEP AT A TIME.
WHAT YOU DON’T WANT TO DO IS
HAVE THIS GO BACK ON US.
>> Bill: SO WHAT ARE THE
SIGNPOSTS THAT YOU WILL USE TO
TELL YOU WE ARE MOVING IN THIS
DIRECTION AND THINGS AT THE
MOMENT ARE A-OK, WHAT ARE THOSE
INDICATORS?
>> I’M NOT SURE THEY ARE GOING
TO BE A-OK BECAUSE WHEN YOU HAVE
PEOPLE DYING IN YOUR STATE, IT’S
NOT OKAY, BUT WE’VE NOW GOT THAT
CURVE FLATTENED.
BUT WE WOULD HOPE TO START
SEEING IS HOSPITAL ADMISSION
START GOING DOWN AND TRACKING IN
THAT DIRECTION.
OUR CHALLENGE TODAY OR WHENEVER
A OUR BIG CHALLENGES AS OUR
HOT SPOTS AND THIS IS IN A PLACE
WHERE YOU HAVE CONGREGATE
LIVING.
WE HAVE A BIG FLAREUP IN PRISON,
FLAREUPS AND DIFFERENT NURSING
HOMES, SO THAT’S WHAT’S DRIVING
THE SOME OF THESE NUMBERS AS
OHIOANS HAVE DONE A VERY, VERY
GOOD JOB AT DISTANCING, BUT THE
PEOPLE IN THOSE SITUATIONS CAN’T
REALLY DISTANCE OR DISTANCE VERY
MUCH, SO THAT CONTINUES TO DRIVE
SOME OF THESE NUMBERS AND
TRAGICALLY, SOME OF THE DEATHS
COMING OUT OF THESE NURSING
HOMES.
>> Bill: IT’S REALLY
HEART-WRENCHING.
I SAW MICHIGAN IS MAKING A MOVE
TOWARDS MAY 1ST AS WELL.
IS THERE COORDINATION REGIONALLY
REGIONALLY?
YOU TOOK A STEP IN AND SHUT YOUR
STATE DOWN WITHOUT COORDINATION
FROM OTHER STATES.
DO YOU NEED COOPERATION WITH
OTHERS OR CAN YOU DO THIS
STEP-BY-STEP ON YOUR OWN,
GOVERNOR?
>> WE ARE GOING TO DO IT, GOING
TO BE AN OHIO DECISION MADE BY
OHIOANS BUT YOU CAN ALWAYS LEARN
SOMETHING BY TALKING TO OTHER
GOVERNORS AND OTHER PEOPLE IN
SIMILAR CIRCUMSTANCES SO
KENTUCKY AND INDIANA, OHIO, WE
TALK EVERY WEEK.
WE HAVE JOINED AN INFORMAL
GROUP, WE’VE DONE THE SAME THING
WITH ALL THE GREAT LAKES STATES
IN THAT GROUP BEING INCLUDES
KENTUCKY AS WELL SO THIS IS JUST
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
EXCHANGE IDEAS AND SEE WHAT
EVERYBODY ELSE IS DOING BUT WE
ARE NOT GOING TO GO LOCKSTEP AND
FOR THE BUCK STOPS WITH ME AND
MAKING THE DECISIONS AND WE WILL
DO THAT IN CONSULTATION WITH
OHIOANS IN THE WHITE HOUSE AND
OTHER GOVERNORS.
>> Bill: I’VE GOT 30 SECONDS
LEFT.
THIS IS A BIG QUESTION FOR 30
SECONDS ON THE SCREEN FOR OUR
VIEWERS, THE NUMBER OF JOB
LOSSES IN OHIO.
855,004855,004 WEEKS.
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES SHOOTING
SKY-HIGH NOW AT 5.5%.
THAT HAS TO BE A MEASURE OF YOUR
DECISION-MAKING NOW, DOESN’T IT?
>> IT DOES, AND THERE ARE
CONSEQUENCES, MEDICAL
CONSEQUENCES WHEN UNEMPLOYMENT
SHOOTS UP LIKE THAT.
A LOT OF BAD THINGS HAPPEN AND
WE CAN LOSE A LOT OF PEOPLE JUST
BECAUSE OF THAT DOWNWARD
ECONOMY, SO WE KNOW WE’VE GOT TO
DO THINGS, WE HAVE TO BE VERY
CAREFUL HOW WE DO IT BUT WE’VE
GOT TO BRING THINGS UP SO WE CAN
GET MOVING AGAIN.